sean if someone were to tell you that
filmmaking is a pipe dream
what would you tell them i've always
been a believer in
and again my parents have probably
get all the credit for this but you can
accomplish anything you set your mind to
so there's many things that can be a
pipe dream uh
if you let them be a pipe dream but if
it's really
in your core and your soul and your
energy to
pursue being a filmmaker i think you
have to
pursue it and that's really up to you
if if you are someone who
has to express yourself that way
and uh i i also come from that mindset
and maybe it's the martial arts
uh but also families that never give up
never surrender type of
uh attitude so for me
uh i have
pursued this business in a i think an
interesting way i i've done
just about every job you can do in
filmmaking uh
from hair and makeup to you know to
stunt coordination to
i've always been and i had a mentor
early on
in this business who told me to
diversify or die and i've really
kind of took that to heart and as long
as i was working on
a film or television show i viewed it as
number one educational
uh to the ultimate goal which is you
know directing
for myself um i viewed it as an
education
and i was getting to be a part of
something that i love which is telling
stories
uh so um
i think pipe dreams are uh
only limited by your own drive
um and so again if
you don't give up i believe you can make
it
so a lot of the people that i have
been lucky enough to collaborate with
over the years
the stories are almost the same it's
they didn't give up and all these
overnight successes you
you read or hear about they're usually
10 years 20 years in the making
and so it's those people that with that
drive
that end up having success
on a multitude of different levels
how many people were in the town where
you grew up
uh roughly like
30 to 50 000 people uh it's is kind of
the population when i was
when i was growing up it's probably more
now uh but it was also a college town so
when college students were in it it was
like double
and do they have a film program there or
i don't know if they have a film there
is a lot of theater so like uh
my father was a drama professor he
directed two plays a year he produced
shakespeare in the park
so there's a lot of arts that way um as
far as film goes i think you can study
some film
at both chico state and and butte
college but
i don't know if it's a full-blown film
program
at least it wasn't when i grew up there
maybe they do have something
like that now so did you ever drive down
or or fly down from chico to the la area
and see what it was like here
i did so i still have family who were
down
in southern california both san diego
some in
in los angeles so um
i did spend time and also my
grandparents when i was younger they
still lived in
chatsworth so i spent time
there for that and then also
i would come down for summers and visit
family
i visited my family down in san diego
from probably like 14 through like 20. i
would come down every summer
and stay with my aunt and uncle um and
uh
so yeah so i was very familiar with
southern california it wasn't uh
it wasn't a culture shock when i moved
down here in that way
there was other things that you know
sure i i wasn't expecting but uh
um i at least had some inclement in
clean you know
well i think uh um moving to
uh la itself i think i didn't
fully grasp what traffic meant you know
even living in san diego there's traffic
but when you live live in los angeles
like really fully understanding oh that
it's five miles away but that still
means an hour in traffic
you know like that i think those kinds
of things i couldn't prepare for
um and uh
you know um i certainly think
what i actually thought was interesting
is
sometimes los angeles might get a bad
rap like oh everybody's so rude or this
or that
i think i kind of had an opposite
experience i'm like man people are
actually really nice and you know people
say hello to me all the time and you
know like
so almost i became a defender of los
angeles in that way i'm sure that
there's rude people everywhere and
especially in traffic that's when you
get the rude people i think
but uh you know walking around the
streets of of
you know everywhere i mean hollywood to
to to burbank to
uh you know the valley um i've met such
wonderful people and
and created such great friendships and
so i think there's a lot of
uh uh misnomer i think same thing with
new york
you hear that you know that new york
people might have a chip on their
shoulder or something
but again if you go there and experience
it and live there i think you you'll
find a lot of great people too
sure it seems like too that you can you
kind of have a way of fitting into any
environment you go in i get that sense
that you
you adapt i guess that's probably true
yeah i think i am very adaptable
and i try and uh find common ground with
people
and i believe that's probably a a great
tool to have
if you're going to be a collaborator so
myself as a
director or somebody who's capped you
know being the captain of that ship
i try and lead through uh
that idea of collaboration like we're
all working together for the same goal
i'm definitely not a it's my way or the
highway guy i
i do have a strong vision and i do know
what i want
but i'm open to you know all the
different ideas that can make
that vision even better than maybe what
i was expecting so
um uh you know
so i'm very open-minded that way and i
think that that
open-mindedness is what allows me to be
adaptable and
and fit in and work in different
situations and
um i've just found it very useful i
think
obviously uh given my parents and family
credit but also the martial arts angle
of it i think
uh the philosophy of martial arts is
is very much that way studying something
called tai chi
uh it is all about accepting energy and
redirecting it
versus you know trying to like you know
go
head on you know blunt force uh you know
trauma with something it's more about
accepting that energy redirect if it's
something negative you can let it just
go right by you
um if it's something useful you can
accept it and maybe redirect it
in in the way that you're um you know
approaching a problem-solving situation
or
um you know being creative knowing that
you had this quote-unquote
filmmaking dream and you figured you
were definitely coming to la and this
was going to be your path
what were the three obstacles the
biggest obstacles that held you back
from maybe initially achieving it or
from
um yeah okay i think
i think some of the biggest obstacles
were maybe just kind of coming from that
maybe smaller town mentality like it
growing up becoming a filmmaker didn't
even
actually seem like a plausible dream
you know uh it just wasn't even
something that i really thought about
it's like oh no you got to go to college
you got to get your
you know you got to get your associate's
degree you know like
it just seemed like a different path so
as i started you know when i made that
leap and moved down to southern
california i didn't go right to la
and so maybe there was part of that just
not
you know fully believing uh it is really
possible i think
part of me was like yes it's possible
then other parts of me were
like oh that's just a you know
how would you even do that how would you
even accomplish that so i think
that that kind of uh maybe self-doubt
is definitely probably one of the bigger
obstacles um
i think just logistics like like
figuring out
what am i gonna do when i get there like
how how are you gonna
um you know just pay rent um
so that's probably some of it um and
then again
education i think taking those i took
uh some uh film history classes in
in college um and
that really opened my eyes and then also
having a teacher i took a creative
writing class and then discovered he
also taught a script writing class
and so i ended up taking that as well so
i think some of that education also
helped
me decide that yes i could you know
pursue this in
it at some level um and sorry didn't
it's already interrupted but you
actually took the same class three times
so the the the history of film class
that was
was taught at san marcos college down in
um san diego area was
a great class so i took the first class
and it was alfred hitchcock and so we
went through the
um his film history like from the very
first film he did all the way to the
last film and uh
we didn't watch every film but we you
know from the different eras we
he would pick a film and we'd watch it
and so we broke it down we studied the
techniques we
the different things that they you know
the filmmaker would like to do
and how they interacted with actors like
the full thing it was fascinating and i
loved it
and at the end of the semester i asked
him
you know do you do the same filmmaker
every time he goes no every semester is
different like well who are you doing
next he's uh well i'm going to do
stanley kubrick i'm like oh my god i got
to take this class again
so i did i ended up taking it three
times during my time there
and studied three different filmmakers
and
i didn't get credit at all on basically
just auditing the class
um but i just really wanted to learn
about those filmmakers and
i think that was a really great
education um
and there was a different teacher for
the creative writing and script writing
but
i think after getting that education uh
probably helped boost my confidence
uh and then i met and married my wife
and she was like why are we in san diego
and i had done a short film and she
loved it uh
she was you know rooting in my corner
she's like this is amazing you've got to
go
we put in some film festivals and did
good with it but um
but it was really her saying you can do
all this from san diego but
you know why not go and try you know try
it up there and so we did we moved up
there on a whim
and uh the rest is history i ended up
i was doing personal training when i
first moved uh to la
to to pay the bills but i got a job
really quickly
in uh in um
uh production being a pa and doing all
that stuff
no job was ever too small for me i was
never afraid of hardware i did
extra work as well and i would i would
bring a a
notebook and painted i would take notes
and i would study and try and learn like
i viewed it as an opportunity
to get on set and see what it's all
about
learn the terms what do they all mean
what's that person's got to be in a mark
okay what you know what's minimal focus
distance mean i
literally would would try and learn
every aspect of what was going on
uh and again i felt i treated it like i
was getting paid to get an education
so so i had no problem i did i did extra
work for probably nine months
ended up getting my sag card through
that um
and at the same time i was personal
training and then i got the pa job on a
tv show and
i self through my own little short films
and things like that
in commercials i had taught myself
how to edit uh on on you know on a mac
one of the early like imovie and
final cut was first coming out and the
whole adobe suites were just starting
out when i was
was doing that and so i taught myself
all the
all the different little tools from
photoshop to after effects
you know to editing and so i had some
other skills
for my own short films and that pa job i
did on a television show of course i put
on my resume
i can do final cut i can do after
effects i can do that
and it wasn't even a week into that
production when
they said hey we saw you do after
effects on uh on your resume
like we were under you know some crazy
deadlines
do you think you could help with some
rotoscoping i'm like oh yeah i've done
that before you know
so they gave me a couple shots and i did
them i turned them in they're like oh
this looks really good you think you
could do some more
oh sure sure yeah no problem so i think
that attitude of always
just being there ready to help ready to
work
helped me excel uh through
through this business like like wildfire
so
one week into being a coffee runner on
this tv show
the very next so i stayed they go well
do you think you can work on a saturday
and help us
no problem i'll be there showed up help
did
did many different things for visual
effects not just rotoscoping i ended up
compositing some pieces i ended up
doing some like lighting effects and
different things in there
by that monday i was a vfx
artist on the show then one week later i
became
the lead green screen effects artist on
the show
so just within two weeks just because i
was ready to go i was willing to put in
the work
and um just having that positive
attitude and also
like we first started talking about this
being able to kind of
blend in or or fit into any situation
having that flexibility is i think what
helped me excel and that happened on
other shows as well
i was a assistant stunt coordinator on a
show
and literally the third day of filming i
ended up becoming the second unit
director on that show oh wow
and it literally had to do with i think
perception is also being perceptive
is also a handy tool um i was
helping this the stunt coordinator
helped with casting all the stunt
uh people for this show and it was an
action
oriented show so we had to choreograph
and rehearse and do all these things
and i saw the executive producer pacing
on like day two
back and forth frustrated and
just being you know just trying to be a
nice guy just hey are you okay
you know and he starts telling me about
how they're not making their days and
and they don't know what to do and uh
the director's moving too slow and
and i just threw out there just going
hey well you know the stunt coordinator
and myself we're both directors
and i had actually already directed a
feature at that point
and i said if you gave us a camera
we could you know more than uh likely
help you
guys film stuff and and hopefully make
your day i said
whatever scenes you want to give us
whatever pieces you want to give us i
know we could handle it
and the very next day he showed up with
a
little like skeleton camera crew and
said sean all right you're gonna
second unit direct this stuff which at
that point i got actually a little bit
terrified because i was now going over
my boss's head the stunt coordinator
because like the second unit director is
almost the next step up
and so i immediately went to him like oh
my gosh i told him that
you and i are both directors because we
have both directed that
us as a team could help i didn't say
that i
should be the director you know and and
luckily
he's a great friend of mine i've
probably done the most work with him
than anybody else in this business
uh noelle vega is his name a wonderful
wonderful
uh friend and uh collaborator in this
business for me
we've probably done over a hundred
projects together because we've worked
on video games together we've worked on
stunt stuff we he's
been a producer and i've been a director
on projects uh tel entire television
series we've done together so we've
really done a lot of stuff
over the years and he just he's also one
of my mentors and kind of like that big
brother
uh in this industry for myself but so i
was
mortified in that situation going i by
no means was trying to
go over your head or try and pass you up
and
uh luckily he was like i'm
so busy as the stunt coordinator he's
like you go do this
you go do it and he championed me for
that and and
uh it worked out well because whatever i
shot
was good enough for them i guess and so
then i became the second unit director
for the whole series and then ended up
fully directing several episodes as the
season went on and
into season two but that's an important
lesson it sounds like because you learn
to like go to him so it didn't seem like
you were trying to go behind his back
yes that's a very stereotypical thing
that happens in this industry
and people do it all the time and yeah
yeah yeah i found out well at least it's
been my experience that loyalty
um in a positive way obviously there
could you know loyalty
could in certain situations maybe not be
a great thing but sure
most situations is a good thing but but
for myself my personal experience
loyalty has been a very um positive
uh tool um and i've only grown
from those loyalties and those
friendships and those you know i've
never
and i'm just not that person as well i
don't to
ever you know betray or step on somebody
to get
to get to that next level i'm much more
the person let's all build ourselves up
together we're stronger as a team
and you know i love the whole brat pack
and the rat packs and that whole idea
like let's make our own
film family and and grow and
uh and and uh
do it that way versus i'm gonna climb to
the top and step on whoever i can to get
there you know
i think in some ways it's a slower
process right uh
not just stepping on people and getting
to the top as fast as you can
um but obviously i think it's a more
fulfilling way to do it and
i have stayed positive and happy in this
business i've been in it now 20 years
um versus feeling you know jaded or
hate myself for the things that i've
done you know what i mean
uh type of thing can i ask you what was
your first job growing up like an
after-school job
oh my gosh um i don't know why it's
coming to my it's like i'm
seeing like you doing something and i
can't totally see what it is but i
was so busy yeah and you know i'm one of
those people who likes doing
a lot of things at once like if you give
me one task it's probably way harder for
me than if you give me three tasks
right so i think uh uh
my first job technically my very first
job was teaching martial arts
oh really so that's what it was and uh
kind of i would i would teach a class
here and there as a teenager as a
teenager
and then i went and got a job at taco
bell
and i worked at taco bell because i
really wanted to save up for the honda
civic hatchback
nice you know i was like 15 and a half
and i started working at taco bell
and my martial arts master uh the the
the head honcho of the system the karate
is a shorin rue karate
a very very traditional okinawan karate
he came through the drive-through
and he saw me there and he's like why
are you working here and i go what do
you mean why am i working here i'm going
i'm saving up for this car and
he goes but you could be working at the
dojo
and i'm like i can he goes yeah i'll pay
you to teach classes
like so i did so i i i did work there
for a little while longer but then i i
went to the to the school to the martial
arts school
and i taught full-time uh for years and
years
but i did have multiple jobs still i
also worked in a stereo store i also
worked at a local
uh baseball like for the baseball
seasons i would go and work there so i
always liked having a lot of jobs and
and then i also started directing those
commercials at that same period
um so yeah i had like three or four jobs
kind of always
uh going on but uh but martial arts
i guess it was because i did teach some
classes so it's either martial art to
taco bell
toss-up between the two but those were
the first jobs
what a great story so he when you went
to give him his order like he's like
yeah i'll have the numbers i was working
the drive-through
and then okay great did you want to have
this yeah and then
and then you're like oh my gosh it's him
okay
yeah well that's a great moment right
yeah it was it was pretty uh
it was pretty funny and uh and just the
look on his face he's like no
come teach at the school you know so but
you know what i think working at taco
bell also taught me a lot of great
lessons and sure people's skills yeah
yeah yeah it's it's uh all of those
i think all those things are important
and and i have kids and
i want them to get you know they're
going to have to earn a car in the same
way i did i had to i saved up
now my parents did help me with some i
think they paid for the insurance and
stuff like that on the car but um i
think there was something so fulfilling
about
that experience and and earning
something like that
i think it was 2 700 at the time for the
car wow
and i that took me you know six months
at taco bell and
and several more months at teaching
martial arts to save up for it but i did
and i just i loved that car i mean that
was you know
because i earned it you know it's the
first like bigger item that i earned
so certainly something in the thousands
of dollars you know
i'd bought saved up and bought bikes and
things like that but never
um you know i think that's part of that
coming of age and
you know oh yeah all that stuff so what
was the first song you blasted through
the stereos because did you get your
stereo from the stereo store
of course oh you did of course and i had
a really big boom in stereo it was
ridiculous
what was absolutely
of course i'm trying to think of what it
would have been
at the time um i like smaller towns have
that
gorgeous circles oh yeah especially
downtown chico it's definitely a cruise
that's you do a loop and we would when i
was 16 we would do the loop we would
circle
several times and and thought we were
very cool
uh with our ridiculous stereos um
it's a rite of passage yeah everybody's
definitely definitely
it felt like uh an 80s version of
american graffiti you know it was very
much that
um which is funny because i've shot
several movies in petaluma
and that's american graffiti was was
shot uh some of it was shot there as
well
the whole cruising the strip was shot in
petaluma oh very cool
um but uh yeah i'm trying to remember i
i listen to such a variety of music i
also play music
so i play guitar and bass and mess
around on the drums and stuff so i've
always
have such a respect for music kind of in
all genres
so i honestly i you know maybe i don't
listen to as much country but there's
still
a lot of country that i really view as
amazingly you know
uh artistic and talented people
performing so i will listen
or maybe it's uh you know opera maybe
i'm not an opera guy
every day on my stereo but there's some
amazing music and such amazing talent
that i
have respect for it so um i'm trying to
think of what
everything from tom petty to oh nice to
uh it might have been a tom petty song i
listened a lot
used to love the cars back then oh yeah
yeah
i played a lot of that but then i'd play
on the opposite end of spectrum i would
play
you know bob marley to zap and roger
to frank zappa you know like i really
i really was uh i kind of have a very
broad spectrum of music that i love
eric clapton i was like obsessed with
eric clapton when i was 16.
nice that's kind of that's when i was
really getting into playing the guitar
and stuff
was listening to everything he did um
so okay yeah probably tom petty or
something probably
free falling right okay probably blast
in and you know
head out the window like ace ventura at
the time or something and the arm too
yeah
oh yeah totally totally yeah
you